[Music]
so there's a plan
to put bitcoin in mouse dna
using a genetically engineered virus
you're welcome enjoy that enjoy that
title for a second let it
rub they're going to sequence this code
in the dna so then the mouse can hold it
so we can send it to each other that's a
digital wallet just send each other mice
yes
exclusive digital wallet private key
for a bitcoin wallet right so you have
the private key
if you encode it into dna
using this method whoa then you could
have
a code that not only lives inside of a
mouse but actually gets passed on to
every generation of the mouse can you
find it right that's too scary mice
don't live that long but it's passed on
generationally but but they got to keep
[ __ ] that's scary
mice love the [ __ ] but but it might
replicate too much and then the [ __ ]
squeaks are going to be translatable and
you get your [ __ ] jacked
all i want well don't say that yet we
just started that video
translatable today
you guys remember at the bank where we
[ __ ] used to use the tube and then
write the checks and then foof right
imagine in the future you put your
[ __ ] mouse and you stop
adam said just a big one
how come it feels like we're going
backwards yeah why do they do what so
what's the function it's like a [ __ ]
messenger pigeon what the [ __ ] right we
already got twitter listen the idea of
it it's really really small project
right now there's a there's a
decentralized autonomous organization or
dao connected to this little scheme
right and the plan is to experiment with
genetic technology to put bitcoin inside
of the mouse it's because one day we can
[ __ ] bitcoin our dna and then we'll
always have it in our wallet which is
our blood oh sure but what if i want to
remove that code isn't it kind of easy
to get what if i want to spend my
bitcoin then i got it it's like diabetes
you got to draw blood every time well if
you smoke calm spend your bitcoin it
goes out of your wallet and it goes in
somewhere else so this is your wallet
right
here oh but what if i lose my [ __ ]
wallet
what are you gonna do blood transfusion
you should you a jizz in the computer
what are you getting like a an accident
and then you know like you're they have
to do blood transfusions or you have to
you know like you give your blood to
someone else now they have your address
you code yourself and then you go to a
blood drive
oh
oh what if someone's sucking on your
dick and then [ __ ] takes the [ __ ] and
goes
and then [ __ ] downloads the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then now they got your bitcoin
dude
that's a hacker right yeah
thank you they're not thinking
new age hackers just have to blow
everyone and you're too stunned from
coming that you don't see them doing it
and there's like like a circle over your
head with ducks
it's like it's like he's gonna be out
for at least four four more minutes
a big jack guys
she's jacking me hard this came hard
the idea is that uh you know in a way
it's an art project that's what they're
saying right it connects the crypto
world with the art world as well as the
biological realm through the idea of
putting bitcoin in a mouse this is
[ __ ] crazy we explore con the
consensus on the value of crypto and our
vision of for the future of the
technology we don't make a biochemical
monster is what they say as part of
their like little light paper for this
so it's just the address
this is probably the wallet it's a
barbecue the private key what's the
private key turkey is which is the power
and this is not the chirping noise
oh that's the top song
better than taylor swift
so yeah no yeah that's the idea right is
that um
uh you
you have the private key the private key
is what unlocks your wallet your wallet
address can be seen by anybody on the
blockchain it's everywhere right
everybody can see it but you can send
and receive from it yeah but the private
key is what gives you control over it
allows you to sign transactions i feel
like that's like so much more grounds
for murdering somebody for their money
versus just stealing their like ledger
or something i agree with you so that's
what it is it's pretty much a ledger
uh yeah kind of yeah it was the key to
the legend
you could get it from spit so they'll be
like making out with you [ __ ] so the
future of robberies is gonna be like
give me your mouth [ __ ] and then you're
just [ __ ] making out with steve or
whatever and you spit in the cup yeah or
you could just you always gotta have a
cup just have a spit in the car oh he's
gotta got because he got with you to
steal your stuff it's just a block of
hair but yeah no no oh you want a sliver
you wanna slide more like a ledger than
you would be able to use this to sign
transactions with without sharing your
private key that's what it looks like i
see so this is different because you
would you have the private key itself
exposed technically it's in your dna
make out scenarios and income swapping
scenarios i feel like a grandpa dude
it's dna holy [ __ ] i don't like that
they can spread it's true like i shake
my dandruff and [ __ ] they got too much
dna now they got my keys everywhere so
that's why they're saying um
exactly because you could breed it right
so they're saying the plan is to work
with the company to translate the key
into a corresponding atgc sequence with
genetic sequence that they code
like the dna
with the um private key during
fertilization and then they rely on a
mouse surrogate for gestation until its
birth and if that doesn't work
bit mouse dao which is what the
decentralized autonomous organization
has chosen as their name will just
engineer a harmless virus carrying the
key and inject it into mice that you
could actually see can you imagine if if
this happened to humans where your kids
can have the keys you want that [ __ ]
back [ __ ] using your bitcoin [ __ ] no
dude i don't know
this sounds like a very
interesting and terrible experiment
why is it terrible to you
for all the reasons that i feel like
everybody just joked about in the last
like five minutes well how do you how do
you get your key onto dna without
everyone who administered it also having
your key
[ __ ] no that's some science questions
wouldn't everybody who worked on that
yeah i mean how to buy a biochem they
got they got lab coats it's like it's
like when you [ __ ] are trying to buy
something and then the guy behind the
counter is like oh yeah you want to play
with the car just tell me your pin
it's that it's like why would you
[ __ ] drill them there
you'd have to be the scientist yourself
to know that's how a lot of people
unfortunately fall for lost games and
put their private key all the time don't
do that please don't do that yeah don't
do that guys okay can i like cut
anthony's hair and then now go to
[ __ ] vons and get some oranges
[Music]
what is the oranges part do i don't even
know
he said what is that oranges part two
well like you know what this is sweat i
guess
yeah anything anybody any bodily part so
then what do you do with the orange this
is definitely one of those things we're
like let's just see what happens let's
see we can actually do it yeah that's
what it seems like i'm sure it up there
stop price just announcing they're doing
it and let's try it yeah even though
there's like and they don't even know
necessarily that the private key will be
translated to the to the children of the
mouse right so ideally the offspring of
the bit mouse would also carry the
private key and they would make
specimens of them to sell at auction
after they died of natural causes
which is kind of [ __ ] weird and crazy
and at that point a single bitcoin was
split into multiple specimens but as
soon as someone breaks the specimen to
extract the genetic information and thus
remove the bit mouse see you see break
the specimen to extract that also sounds
like kill the [ __ ] and take the
d right they're also gotta [ __ ] break
the mouse in half like a
like a safe it's like i need my private
class it's a terrible idea i'm not
accounting for something so uh when
animals breed there's also chances for
mutation right so the dna sequence agtc
whatever it can whatever sequence it is
those letters can also
accidentally through evolution switch
and if that switches then there goes
your [ __ ] bitcoin address whatever
then you end up with more bitcoin right
or you can't log in it's the wrong one
it's a double spend and triple spend
quadruple spend oh 5x off that mouse way
to mine bitcoin it's like either down
syndrome bitcoin or like x-men bitcoin
right are you saying one's better than
the other
are you saying one that's your question
i'm asking i like down syndrome kids
they're like [ __ ] awesome there's a
show called get down with shawn and
marley it's a down syndrome cooking show
oh they're the best it's my favorite
youtube channel right now i love that
channel and i subscribe to it and i also
join their patreon everybody should
watch
yep it's my favorite thing make sure you
like this video and smash that like
button mm-hmm and join our patreon see i
did it this time we didn't do it in the
video
good luck
is it challenger x-men's person i was
just trying to play yo ganaka and just
understand
it could be both it could be cool
yeah
where he tried to what he was always
scrubbing in the shower to get his dna
off or when he had to [ __ ] chop his
legs so you can get taller or something
you